well law enforcement across the country
is stretched thin here in the valley it
means officers must prioritize which
incidents they respond to but as 8 news
now reporter Ryan Matthey shows us
Security Office officers may help to
fill in that Gap
everything's been triple checked
violence in the valley ready and
security officers and instructors like
Bill norvel prepping to respond safer
less Force utilized more technique more
control it's all about getting the bad
guys under control
Security Service protective Force
International teaching some 14 officers
exactly that active threat response in
areas just like this where squatters and
others frequent causing damage these
security officers here preparing to
respond to that and much more focus on
that door we can't sit back and wait
they need somebody to come help them now
you can't wait 10-15 minutes 30 minutes
we've got to be ready to push the threat
safely efficiently from schools to homes
to the strip officers learning how to
act fast in close proximity to Rowdy
intoxicated tourists violent gang
activity homeless confrontations and
other service calls to bridge a gap our
economy is based on tourism so if Vegas
isn't safe nobody's going to come here a
gap Jonathan Alvarez CEO of protective
Force International says comes from
Staffing shortages fewer resources and
altered public perceptions and local law
enforcement the goal he says to respond
when police cannot for a safer Community
putting standards in higher standards
within our industry only promote the
ability ability to respond to
circumstances and critical incidents a
lot better
and trust me when I say it's not as easy
as it may look
yes
well Alvarez says not all security
officers are given this opportunity now
those wanting the training must first
pass a written test oral board law
examination and even a background check
now they expect more training in the
coming months Kirsten